contre seulement neuf lors de
l'arrivée d'Élisabeth II sur le
trône.
- Duntnt cette visite au Kenya,
le père d'Elisabeth, le roi
George VI, meurt.
Propulsant la jeune princesse
sur le trône, à l'âge de 25 ans.
Ceoyagenen Afrique
sera marquant.
La reine gardera une affection
particulière pour le Kenya,
qu'elle visitera trois fois.
A cette époque, une douzaine de
nations africaines sont enrere
des colonies britanniques.
PATRICK TAILLON, prof. droit
constitutionnel Université Laval
- Les années 1950, les années
1960, sont des années où la
question de l'Afrique est une
priorité, elle est au coeur
de l'actualité.
Donc, est-ce que c'est par
affection ou c'est pour défendre
des intérêts stratégiques
importants? Peu importe, le
résultat est là.
Quand Elizabeth II es
couronnée, l'empire britannique
est déjà pratiquement rayé de la
carte. Durant la première moitié
du 20e siècle, le Royaume Uni
laisse aller ou perd la plupart
de ses colonies, dont l'Inde, en
1947.
- ncnc dans la mesure où
certains États, notamment
l'Inde, choisissent de
devenir... d'épouser
la forme républicaine, le
Commonwealth s'effrite dans une
certaine mesure, parce que
soudainement, la communauté
d'intérêts est moins intense.
(acclamations)
- En 1953, le Commonwealth n'a
que 4 ans d'existence et 7 pays
membres. La jeune reine doit
opérer une transition délicate.
Transformer l'ancien empire
colonial en regroupement libre
de pays souverains.
Dès le début de son règne,
Sa Majesté elle prend l'habitude
de visiter régulièrement les
États de son royaume.
En 1953 et 54, elle fait une
tournée de six mois, dans une
dizaine de pays.
En Australie, elle visite toutes
les grandes villes, toutes les
régions, même l p plus reculées.
75 % des Australiens seraient
allés voir la reine sur son
parcours.
- Même si ça reste un rôle
symbolique, les symboles sont
puissants et c'est clair que
lorsqu'on occupe des fonctions
qui sont pas politiquement
déterminantes, on peut quand
même, par des gestes, par des
façons de manifester de
l'intérêt à l'endroit de
certaines choses, avoir une
certaine influence.
- Élisabeth II se donne comme
mission d'utiliser toute la
puissance du symbole royal pour
préserver les liens, économiques
et politiques, entre le
Royaume-Uni et ses anciennes
colonies.
Dans les années 1960,
elle déploie plusieurs
opérations charme en Afrique
pour convaincre les nouvelles
nations indépendantes de se
joindre au Commonwealth.
En 1961, le Ghana est
indépendant depuis quatre ans,
le président Nkrumah commence à
emprisonner ses opposants, à se
rapprocher du bloc soviétique et
menace de seetetirer du
Commonwealth.
Le premier ministre britannique
juge qu' v voyage royal est trop
risqué, mais la reine
s'y rend quand même.
C'est assurément la visite
royale la plus controversée de
l'histoire, dit le journaltete
de la BBC. La reine a 11 jours
pour convaincre Nkrumah de se
rallier au Commonwealth.
Sa Majesté n'hésite pas à
parader de longues heures sous
un soleil ardent aux côtés du
président controversé et même à
danser avec lui.
Elisabeth II est accueillie
comme une star, presque partout
où elle débarque, comme ici à
New Delhi; 2 millions d'Indiens
accueillent le convoi royal.
Pendant 60 ans, elle va profiter
de cette affection du public
pour consolider le Commonwealth
et le faire grandir.
Comme on peut le voir lors de
sommets plus récents, où le
prince Charles est désormais
invité, comme futur chef du
Commonwealth.
De sept pays en 1953,
l'organisation regroupe
aujourd'hui 54 États membr..
La reine était toujours la
cheffe d'État de 15 de ces pays,
qu'on nomme les  Royaumes du
Commonwealth .
Le Canada en fait partie.
- Dans les quinze États qui
restent, il y aura, la prochaine
succession sera hautement
importante, parce que chaque
État aura un peu à se remettre
en question.
Cela posera inévitablement la
questi: : on arrête ou on
continue.
- Le décès d'Elizabeth II
pourrait-il amener le Canada à
abolir la monarchie? Notre
constitution très difficile à
modifier sera-t-elle un
obstacle?
- Si on se limitait un ordre du
jour qui ne portait que sur la
monarchie, et qu'une réforme à
coût nul, ou au fd d on
conserverait un chef d'État, un
gouverneur qui aurait peu de
pouvoir mais qui jouerait au
fond le rôle nécessaire qui est
le sien dans le système
parlementaire, je pense qu'un
consensus serait possible.
- Parce que l'attachement envers
la reine disparaîtra avec elle
et que le prince Charles est
beaucoup moins populaire, les
abolitionnistes pourraient
réussir à rallier une majorité
de citoyens et de politiciens
à l'idée de ne plus avoir
de roi comme chef d'État.